there was an actor saying that the age
of social media has basically killed the
uh the the movie star it's basically
there are no more movie stars now it's
it's a lot I think a lot less about the
art that you make and more about who you
are as a person because it's a lot more
prevalent and obvious now and it's the
same thing with the president they don't
hide behind this Visage of like the
title now you get to see this guy in his
daily behavior and it's insane look look
sorry man just look at this picture
this is worse this is like 1970s crap
this this this tweet from Joe Biden is
worse than nothing he said after my
speech that I spoke with EPA Michael
Reagan Sherrod Brown Bill Johnson
Shapiro dewine about our ongoing efforts
in East Palestine Ohio I reaffirmed my
commitment to making sure they have
everything they need let me give you the
latest and there is a picture of him
sitting on the phone in I don't know
where he is but it's just like
bro just do nothing and say nothing
because the very least then we can try
to imagine what might you have been
doing